deswegen ist Zug fahren in Polen
deutlich besser als hier bei uns in
Deutschland ich bin letztens von Danzig
nach Warschau gefahren und habe dafür
die erste Klasse im Express Intercity
Premium dem polnischen
höchstgeschwindigkeitszug gebucht die
Fahrt hat 2 Stunden 34 gedauert und ich
habe gerade mal 60 € bezahlt super
pünktlich da die pünktlichkeitsrates in
Polen bei 87,5 % und mein Sitz in der
ersten Klasse auf jeden Fall bequem und
ich hatte genug Platz im Preis wird
inkludiert war ein Heißgetränk ein
Kaltgetränk und ein Snack bzw so ein
kleines Mittagessen Landgericht ich habe
mich dafür so ein Honigkuchen
entschieden es gab allerdings auch
Alternativen wie z.B diesen
dreier-spegel wir sind überpünktlich in
Warschau angekommen und ich muss sagen
Preis Leistungsverhältnis hier auf jeden
Fall zehn von zehn jederzeit wieder